So we want to dive in a little deeper on this idea of code reuse.
And in order to do so,
we should really define what we mean when we say code reuse.
Well, when you're writing software,
reuse of code is the practice of writing generalized code
that can be relied upon to address a variety of different goals.
Now, whenever you notice that two parts of your code have similarities,
there's an opportunity to factor out the similar aspects of it
into some reusable library code so
that you won't have to repeat yourself in either of the two original places.
So here's an example we can use to think about code reuse.
Imagine you wanted to write a simple game that involves cars driving
along a street.
The player is on the run from a crime syndicate and
has to avoid their goons, who drive around in these unmarked vans.
Our program is going to need to keep track of a lot of data about each of
the entities moving around the system, and so
we'll use object-oriented techniques a lot here.
Now that we know what we're shooting for, let's put these mockups away and
focus on the code that we're going to write.